شكرا للعيال اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى
هذه التغطيه المستمره من العربيه لليوم
الثاني من الاشتباكات في السودان الذي
ينتهي بلا افاق من اجل الحل حتى في
الساعات الاربعه التي اعلن الجيش والدعم
السريع عن موافقتهما خلالها على فتح
مسارات امنه للحالات الانسانيه العمليات
العسكريه ستستمر لاكثر من اسبوع بحسب
مصادر بالجيش السوداني هل هناك تفاوض او
حوار محتمل عضو مجلس السياده شمس الدين
كباشي يجيب بلا
نبدا برئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد
الله حمدوك وتصريحاته حول هذا الموضوع
الاقتتال الداخلي السوداني السوداني حيث
حذر من انزلاق السودان نحو حرب اهليه
مشددا على ان السلام هو الخيار الوحيد
لتجنب ذلك المصير
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
يجب
ان تقف هذه الحرب
اليوم قبل غدا
في اتاحه الفرصه
للشعب السوداني بكل مكوناته
ليعود
لمسار الانتقال الذي بدا
من اكثر ما من ثلاثه سنوات
ايضا لن امر تكرار
يظل السلام هو الخيار الوحيد
المتاح للشعب السوداني
لتفادي الانزلاق
للحرب الاهليه
تحذيراته حندوق اطلقها ايضا المتحدث باسم
العمليه السياسيه في السودان خالد عمر
يوسف الذي قال ان الاشتباكات الدائره
ستمزق البلد وستفقده وحدته وسيادته وشدد
يوسف في تغريدات نشرها على حسابه بتويتر
على ضروره توقف هذه الحرب الان وفورا ودون
تاخير لان الدوله السودانيه بحسب وصفه في
اضعف حالاتها وفي اكثرها هشاشه ولن تصمد
امام هذا العنف المتصاعد اعرب خالد عمر
يوسف عن امله في ان تضع القوى المدنيه
الديمقراطيه انقساماتها خلف ظهرها وان
تمسك بزمام المبادره وان تتوحد لانقاذ
البلاد من مصيرها المظلم الذي ينتظرها
بحسب قولها
وعلى وقع تجدد الاشتباكات الليليه كما
تابعنا قبل قليل بين قوات الجيش السوداني
القوات المسلحه برئاسه عبد الفتاح البرهان
وبين قوات الدعم سريع نتابع الان هذه
الصور التي التقطتها الاقمار الصناعيه
لشركه ماكسار والتي تظهر دمار الذي حل في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم جراء
الاشتباكات تظهر الصور الدمار في جسور
الخرطوم والمطار والاضرار التي لحقت بمبنى
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
اخر المعلومات عن الجيش السوداني ان قوات
الدعم السريع تستهدف مناطق سكنيه في
الخرطوم الجيش طلب المواطنين ايضا بالحذر
من القصف العشوائي للدعم السريع واضح من
كل المعطيات حتى الان ان هذا الموضوع ان
لم يحسم سريعا بانه سيستمر لايام على
الاقل ان لم يكن سيطول اكثر وفقا باخر
التصريحات والمعطيات على الارض مكاتب
قناتي العربيه والحدث تضررت في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم بعد وقوع قصف جوي طال
ابراج النيلين حيث توجد مكاتب العربيه
والحدث ولكن دون وقوع اي اصابات
المزيد من الاتهامات من قبل القوات
المسلحه
لقوات الدعم السريع لانها تريد نشر الفوضى
والجيش السوداني يدعوا
المواطنين الى او يدعو الطرف الاخر الى
قواعد اشتباك مهنيه لمنع وقوع ضحايا بين
المدنيين يقول انه يتبع هذه القواعد قواعد
اشتباك المهنيه ولكن يلوم الطرف الاخر على
عدم اتباعها طبعا تتواصل اشتباكات في محيط
القياده العامه للجيش بالعاصمه الخرطوم
ويقع مقر القياده العامه في المنطقه
الشماليه من العاصمه على بعد نحو اربعه
كيلومترات فقط من مطار الخرطوم كما يتواجد
بالقرب من مقر قياده القوات البحريه
ورئاسه اركان القوات الجويه ويعد مقر
القياده العامه مركزا مهما وحساسا بالنسبه
لقوات الجيش السوداني ويستمر اطلاق الرصاص
في محيط المبنى مع تداول اخبار عن استخدام
اسلحه ثقيله
ما الذي يحصل الان مع سالم الهاشمي مراسل
العرب العربيه من الخرطوم اهلا بك معنا
سالم حدث لنا معلوماتنا حول الوضع
الميداني كنا عرفنا اخر ما عرفناه ان
الاشتباكات الليليه قد تجددت
نعم تجددت الاشتباكات الليليه طاهر في
مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم عبر هذه
الاشتباكات بكل تاكيد في مبنى القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني ومحيط مطار الخرطوم
الدولي وكذلك جزئيا في القصر الجمهوري هذه
الاشتباكات يتجددت ويعني لم يعرض بعد اي
طرف يسيطر على هذه المناطق بشكل كامل ولكن
بدون شك هي كانت معارك كروه فر طيله هذين
اليومين فيما يتعلق بهذه المواقع الحساسه
لانه كل طرف يستهدف السيطره عليها بما لها
من اهميه كبرى طبعا في هذه المعركه كان في
مرات تعلن الدعم السريع يعني سيطرتها
الكامله واحيانا اخرى الجيش يعلن سيطرته
كامله ولا يزال الوضع حتى الان غامضا
نعم صحيح وايضا بعد تجدد هذا الاشتباك
الان وقبل دقيقتين من الان بالتحديد ايضا
سمع
العديد من الرصاص وكذلك المدافع الثقيله
وحتى المضادات مضادات الطيران في منطقه
بحري في محيط
الجسر الرابط بين بحري واندرمان وكذلك جسر
وحتى في كوفر الان هناك في تلك المنطقه
دوليه
لمجموعه من الانفجارات كذلك
الاستخدام للاسلحه في تلك المناطق اذا هذا
قبل دقيقتين فقط نحن نتحدث معك سالم عن
مدافع ثقيله ومضادات في منطقه بحري على
عند الجسر بين بحري وام درمان ايضا عن
مجموعه انفجارات في منطقه كوبر حيث السجن
الشهير سجن كوبر في السودان
ايضا الرئيس السابق موجود فيه الرئيس
السابق
هذه التجدد الاشتباكات هذه كانت متوقعه
خاصه بعد نهايه الهدنه التي تحدث فيها
الطرفان على انهم
لمرور المساعدات الانسانيه
قليلا عند موضوع الامور الانسانيه
يعني الهدنه
مهمه جدا ولكن لاكمل بنفس الموضوع
الميداني هل هناك نقاط تماس خطوط تماس
الان في العاصمه الخرطوم على الاقل واضحه
للعيان بين ما هو جيش او قوات مسلحه وما
هو قوه دعم سريع
نعم خطوط واضحه جدا في مناطق الخرطوم وفي
كوبر ايضا اباحيه خطوط تماس واضحه وواقع
مشاريع وليس يلتقيان في هذه المناطق بين
تبادل لاطلاق النار كثيف
بشتى انواع
الاسلحه الثقيله لكل انواعها يتم
هذا الامر ويتم ايضا
تبادل هذه الضربات بصوره مقلقه جدا
ولفترات طويله كذلك هذه مستمره منذ
فجر اليوم وحتى هذه اللحظات ولكننا بما
اننا قلنا انها يعني معارك كروه فار فهي
بالتالي خطوط تماسك يعني غير ثابته هي
متحركه حتى الساعه ولو انها واضحه بالنسبه
الى السودانيين على الارض
صحيح هي متحركه ليست ثابته لكن المنطقه
واحده هي لكن في داخلها يكون هناك الحركه
بين نكرر بين
الضراغين لكن لكل طرف خطوط هو متمركز فيها
يعني يتحرك فيها
بارتياح مثلا الجهه الغربيه من القياده
العامه والجهه الغربيه كذلك من مطار
الخرطوم هذه هي تمركز فيها الجيش السوداني
ومتواجد فيها ولديه دبابات في تلك المنطقه
واما الجهه الشماليه والشرقيه
او عفوا الجهه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه والغربيه هذه الجهات تتمركز فيها
قوات الدعم السريع الجهه الشماليه
والشماليه الغربيه يتمركز فيها
مركز فيها الجيش السوداني ولديه مدرعات في
تلك المنطقه في هذه المنطقه التي هي منطقه
مركزيه تحوي مطار الخرطوم من جهه العمل
للجيش من جهه تمام اخرى هل لدينا معلومات
مؤكده عن مصير الاذاعه والتلفزيون بعد
انقطاع البث يعني اللي عرفناه
لدعوه التلفزيون اخر الانباء التي وردتها
هي حديث الجيش السوداني بالامس انه حرر
مباني الاذاعه والتلفزيون وانها اصبحت
محافظه وتابعه للجيش السوداني لكن مراقب
يرون ان تصديق هذا القول يكون
واحد من الثقابات او حتى ارجاع التاكيد
يعني لازم عوده البث اولا كي يتاكد الناس
من انه الجيش هو الذي يسيطر عليه ماذا غير
واضح يجعل الامر ما زال غير واضح بطبيعه
الحال اذا هذا بخصوص الاذاعه والتلفزيون
الان وعدتك بان نعود الى الوضع الانساني
هو اللي هو سيء جدا للاسف لا كهرباء لا ما
الناس مش قادرين يتحركوا طبعا من اجل يعني
التقاط الانفاس والاتيان باغراضهم
الاساسيه وحاجياتهم اليوميه كيف يتطور
المشهد على الصعيد الانساني هذا
بالنسبه للكهرباء والمياه الجزئيا بدات
تعود التيارات الكهربائيه الجزئيه في بعض
الاحياء فما زالت هناك احياء باكملها لم
يرجع
لكن ليست هذه المعضله الواضحه المعضله
الواضحه انه المحل التجاريه المغلقه امداد
القمح ومعروف
في العاصمه يعتمدون كبيره على الخبز اليوم
ومنذ فتره طويله اول مره تعود صفوف الخبز
في المخارج لكن ان المخارج التي تعمل
لديها حصه
تاتي على اسبوعيه يعني على اسبوع فربما
اصادف هذا يعني 72 ساعه وربما تستمر ربما
تجعل هذه المخابز واضيف الى ذلك كل
المخابز هي تعمل بهذه الظروف خدمات
الاتصالات
خدمات الاتصالات
في خدمه الانترنت
والاتصالات كانت شبكه قد خرجت عن الخدمه
والان عادت لات
صالات فيها بحسب ما وردتنا من التذبذب
ايضا في شبكه زين شبكه سوداني وحدها هي
التي
الان تعمل بشكل جيد في الانترنت
في مكاتبنا سالم حجم الضرر في مكاتبنا
الخارجي في المبنى الخارجي
هناك طبعا للمبنى من الخارج ونقدر لعربات
خارج المبنى وبكل تاكيد عربات فيها يعني
تضررت بشكل
كلي ان نقول يعني
لزملاء واصدقاء نعرفهم تضررت عرباته وكذلك
لكن على مستوى الافراد كل الطاقم بخير
الحمد لله ومن داخل المكاتب ايضا الاجهزه
كلها بخير والحمد لله على سلامتكم ونعمل
يعني ان نقول الحمد لله على السلامه ايضا
لكل فرد من افراد الشعب السوداني اقرب وقت
ممكن
رغم الوقوع عشرات القتلى والجرحى حتى الان
للاسف شكرا جزيلا لك سالم الهاشمي مراسل
العربيه من الخرطوم ونتابع في تغطيتنا هذه
حيث يبدو ان السيطره على القوات على
القواعد العسكريه الجويه الشغل الشاغل لدى
قوات الدعم السريع فالسلاح الجوي وفقاع
عسكريين النقطه الفاصله في المعركه بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع فمن يحكم
السيطره عليها يحسم المعركه
هدف على الارض ففي السودان القوه هنا في
القواعد الجويه قوات الدعم السريع التي لا
تمتلك قوه جويه تعلم ان من يمتلك الاجواء
يحسم المعركه فكانت البدايه من هنا حيث
القوه
اشتعلت المعركه حين اقتحمت قوات حميدتي
احدى القواعد الجويه في الخرطوم اشتبك
الطرفان استخدم الجيش ثلاث طائرات عسكريه
حتى الان خلال الاشتباك ضد قوات الدعم
السريع منذ انتشارها في قاعده مروي حيث
البدايه قاعده مرويه الجويه تقع شمال
السودان تستخدم غالبا في التدريبات
والمناورات الجويه تاتي بعدها قاعده
الخرطوم وسط العاصمه وعلى غرب الخرطوم
هنالك قاعده الابيض شمال ولايه كردفان
وايضا قاعده وادي سيدنا في منطقه ام درمان
بالاجمال هناك ثمان قواعد جويه اهمها
بالنسبه للطرفين قاعده ماروي لاحتوائها
على اكبر عدد من الطائرات واحدثها والاهم
مركز فعال للمراقبه والطائرات بدون طيار
وتليها اكبر قاعده وادي سيدنا وفيها مخاب
ئ الطائرات وعشرات المقاتلات العسكريه
غذاء السالم العربيه
وقد افادت مصادر في الجيش السوداني بان
العمليات العسكريه ستاخذ اكثر من اسبوع
بسبب انتشار الدعم السريع في مجموعات
صغيره وسط الخرطوم واضافت المصادر
اللاحوار او تفاهم قبل استسلام عناصر
الدعم السريع كما قالت المصادر ان قوات
الدعم السريعه فقدت مراكز الاتصال
المركزيه وتتصرف كوحدات منفصله في العاصمه
السودانيه
قال رواء ركن فيصل مختار ساير قائد الفرقه
الرابعه عشره قطاع كادوقلي في ولايه جنوب
كردفان ان قوته سيطرت على قاعده تابعه
لقوات الدعم السريع وحصلت على ثماني عشره
مركبه وعلى كميه من الذخائر اليوم
ثم اتكلم من السيطره
المواقع
كل المواقع
الدامه ريال متمرد
في ولايه الجنوب كردفان في مدينه كادوقلي
والحمد لله العام كل المواقع في تحت سيطره
القواتنا المسلحه
في المقابل قالت قوات الدعم السريع انها
سيطرت على سلاح المهندسين في ام درمان كما
اسقطت مروحيه في الخرطوم بحري
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر استلمنا
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
في تصريحات للعربيه انه غير قادر حتى
اللحظه على التواصل مع رئيس مجلس السياده
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو وضع فضل الله
بورما ناصر البرهان وحماتي لفتح خطوط
هواتفهما حتى تستطيع القوى السياسيه
التواصل معهما
هذا واتهمت قوى الحريه والتغيير في
السودان ما سمتها بفولول النظام السابق
باشعال فتيل الازمه والتعبئه للحرب ودعت
قوى الحريه والتغيير في بيان نشرته على
فيسبوك قيادتي الجيش وقوه دعم سريع لوقف
المواجهات العسكريه فورا والعوده لطاوله
التفاوض
السودان وال
واقع
الان الا وقف اطلاق
النار الفوري والعوده الى طاولات الحوار
والنقاش ايضا ان هناك ما زالت فرصه رقم
الجانبين العسكريين ورقم
الاوضاع الى ما هي عليه نحن ما زدنا نجلس
في جهود كثيره مع الاطراف
الحيه المصارعه
مكاتب قناتي العربيه والحدث تضررت في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم بعد وقوع قصف
جوي طال ابراج النيلين حيث توجد مكاتب
العربيه والحدث ولكن دون وقوع اي اصابات
منذ تفجر الازمه التي بدات بعد التحشيد
العسكري الذين نفذته قوات الدعم السريع في
مناطق بمراوي في الولايه الشماليه القريبه
من القاعده العسكريه الجويه بدات
التساؤلات تطفو الى السطح حول الاسباب
الاعمق لهذا التوتر المزيد في سياق هذا
التقرير
التوتر لا يزال سيد الموقف في السودان
خيوط الخلافات بين مكونين عسكري ومدني
فتحت باب التساؤل حول الاسباب الاعمق لهذا
التوتر وتقود في نهايتها لمارس الماضي
وخلاف ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
الورشه التي اختتمت حينها وسط غيو بقاده
الجيش شهدت خلافات النشبت بين ضباط الجيش
المشاركين في ختام ورشه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري وقاده قوات الدعم السريع ابرز
نقاط الخلاف كان صياغه التوصيات الاخيره
للورشه التي تتطرق لاصلاحات امنيه ابرزها
مساله دمج قوات الدعم السريع مع الجيش
وتواريخ الدمج وتفاصيل الرتب حيث طالبت
ورقه الجيش بحصر دمج قوات الدعم السريع
خلال الفتره الانتقاليه التي حددها
الاتفاق الايطالي باربعه وعشرين شهرا ووضع
ترتيبات امنيه للحركات المسلحه الموقعه
على اتفاق جوبا لسلام السودان وفق جدا
الزمنيه محدده كما تحدد ورقه الجيش ضوابط
ومعايير قبول التحاق ضباط قوات الدعم
السريع وتسرح من تم تعيينهم بعد سقوط نظام
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير وتقنين صلاحيات
الدعم السريع العسكريه والاقتصاديه
والسياسيه من جهه اخرى الخلاف بين الدعم
السريع والجيش ليس خلافا فنيا حول فتره
دمج قوات الدعم السريع والتي تطالب
الاخيره بان تكون خلال عشر سنوات بل هو
خلاف سياسي بسبب تقاطع مواقف قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان حميدتي تجاه العمليه السياسيه
والتحالفات المستقبليه خاصه ان الدعم
السريع نص بتوصياته خلال ورشه الاصلاح
الامني على مراجعه وتطوير العقيده
العسكريه وناي المؤسسه العسكريه عن التدخل
في السياسه لكن الصراع بين الامبراطوريتين
العسكريتين اعمق من مجرد اختلاف على عمليه
دمج القوات فمصادر مقربه من البرهان ودجل
كشفت بانهما ما زال على خلاف حول من
سيتقلد منصب القائد العام للجيش خلال فتره
الاندماج التي ستمتد عده سنوات
شكرا لحضور دكتور اسامه المصطفى الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني معنا هنا في
الاستوديو مسددا اهلا بك معنا دكتور مره
جديد على شاشه العربيه كنا نبحث في
التقرير السابق عن الاسباب العميقه لهذا
الخلاف اذا ما تحدثنا عن ابرز هذه الارصه
الرصاصات من وجهه نظرك ما قاد الى هذه
المالات المريره على الشارع والشعب
السودانيين
الطرفين منذ زمن طويل هنالك صراعات بينهم
الاثنين الصراعات من اجل النفوس والسلطه
الطرفين ايضا
محمد حمدان دقله والسيد البرهان لديهم
ازمه كبيره فيما يتعلق اللي هو
دمج القوات قوات الدعم السريع الى القوات
المسلحه رغم انه القوات الدعم السريعه
التي تم انشاءها في 2014
ضمن
القوات الامن والاستخبارات ثم في 2017
ضمن القوات العسكريه ولكن ضمن فيما يتعلق
بقانون الدعم السريع اللي هو رقم خمسه من
25 في 2019 تم حذف هذا القانون وبالتالي
اصبح الدعم السريع موازنه للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه وهذا امر وضع
باعتراف
السيد البرهان في خطابات يعني الجماهيريه
بانه الدعم السريع جزء من الجيش
في لحظه ما اصبح بالنسبه له الدعم السريع
ليس تابع للجيش وهذا ما اججج الازمه ما
بينه وبين وعزاز وجوده بالتالي والقوته
اذا محاولات المدارات والاحتواء اللي
مارسها الجيش بفتره من الفترات ربما تدفع
البلاد ثمنها الان بالضبط هو بالضبط كما
تربي الطفل صغير
تملك
اشياء معينه عندما يكبر تعطيه سلطه ثم في
لحظه ما تحاول تنتزع منه السلطه بالتاكيد
راح يرفض وهذا ما وضع هذا الوضع تماما
الذي نشهده الان ولكن ايضا هناك واقع في
البلاد عسكري هناك قوه ماليه قوه اقتصاديه
قوه علاقات دوليه ايضا لدى هذا الطرف اي
قوات الدعم السريع السيد محمد حمدان دقلو
وبالتالي ربما يعني البعض قد يقول انه كان
من الحكمه من السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان ان
يحاول احتواءه ولكن وصلت الامور الى ما لا
يحمد الى خط اللاعوده فبالتالي لابد كان
من تفجر الازمه هل نوافق على هذا الكلام
لا اوافق ولكن بشكل اخر عندي وجهه نظر في
هذا الامر محمد من عبد الفتاح البرهان
انقلاب 25 اكتوبر الذي استولى فيه على
السلطه اللي هي كانت المفروض تتحول الى
سلطه مدنيه ظلت هنالك صراعات ما بينه وبين
بيحاول يستاثر بالشارع او بالمدنيين بينما
دائما البرهان رافض مساله التحول
الديمقراطي التحول المدني في الوقت
المناسب وبالتالي عندما نراقب مساله
الاتفاق الايطالي
والتاخير الذي يحدث وكان دائما السبب هو
البرهان في كل المراحل بس كان يحكى ايضا
عن اولا محاوله توزيع ادوار بين الرجلين
او بين الطرفين على الاقل للابقاء على
الوضع كما هو او ثانيا على شروط حاده كان
يضعها الطرف الاخر وهو طرف سيد محمد حمدان
دقلو وليس السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان كيف
ترد تماما هذا الكلام صحيح ولكن البرهان
هو مهد
لمحمد حمدان دقلو ان يكون في هذا الموقع
محمد حمدان دوجلو بيرى انه هو النائب
العام للقوات المسلحه والطموحاته اكبر من
ان يكون في هذا الموقع بما لديه من نفوس
وطاقه
عسكريه الشيء الاخر ونخشه في المرحله
القادمه
المحاوله
يعني ادخال قوات خارجيه كما نعلم علاقه
محمد حمدان ومجموعه
وعلاقه قويه جدا فيها تفاصيل عسكريه من
نيجر الى يعني
حدود الافريقيه افريقيا الوسطى بنفس
الموضوع لدينا عرض نقارن فيه دكتور اسامه
بين قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع نتعرف
اكثر على عدد العناصر والاليات لدى كل من
القوتين ونعود للنقاش
الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع التاسيس
الجيش السوداني تاسس في عام
1925 قوات الدعم السريع تاسست في اغسطس
2013 التعداد العسكري الجيش السوداني يبلغ
نحو ربع مليون جندي قوات الدعم تقدر بنحو
100 الف مقاتل الترسانه العسكريه الجويه
الجيش السوداني لديه 191 طائره حربيه
45 مقاتله 37 طائره هجوميه وخمس وعشرون
طائره شحن عسكريه قوه الدعم لا تمتلك اي
طائرات
الترسانه العسكريه البريه الجيش السوداني
يمتلك 20 منصه صواريخ
170 دبابه
403 مدرعات سبعه الاف مركبه عسكريه قوات
الدعم لديها اسلحه خفيفه ومتوسطه 10 الاف
سياره رباعيه الدفع الجيش السوداني يحتل
المرتبه الخامسه والسبعين عالميا في قائمه
اقوى جيوش العالم
[موسيقى]
ونعود الى الدكتور اسامه المصطفى الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني هنا في
الاستوديو اهلا بك معنا مجددا الدكتور
دعنا يعني نرصد عده عوامل مهمه جدا لصالح
من يمكن ان تميل وفق قراءتك ومعطيات
الساعه على الارض وبحسب المواقف اولا
الناس الشعب هل يمكن ان نقول انهم يمكن ان
ينقسموا تماما كما هو الانقسام الحاصل
حاليا بين قوات الدعم السريع والقوات
المسلحه او انه بحكم بطبيعه الحال
سينحازون الى القواتهم المسلحه
بكل المقاييس الشعب هذه القوات الشعب
المسلحه باعتبار هو اسمه قوات الشعب
المسلحه ربما هو بالرغم من انه هذه القوات
ادلجت في فتره من الفترات فتره الرئيس
البشير
والحكومه السابقه بعد موجود في قيادات
يعني يمكن ان نسميها بدوله عميقه في داخل
الجيش بالتاكيد ولكن الشعب يرى انه قوات
الشع المسلحه هي القبقه القوات المسلحه
قوى الحريه والتغيير هل ترى لها اي دور
حقيقي الان في الانحياز الى احد الاثنين
ضعيفين قوى الحريه التغيير المجلس المركزي
او او الكتله الديمقراطيه هم بشكل او باخر
سبب فيما يحدث الان في السودان بس مش
قادرين يحشدوها بالارض ممكن يؤثروا يعني
الطرفين
يعني القوات المجلس مركز مجلس المركزي كان
دائما
يمارسوا الانانيه
وقايه تبرر الوسيله الوجود الى السلطه باي
شكل من اشكال الكتله الديمقراطيه يعني
نعرف انه هم مجموعه قوات حركات مسلحه
وعنده اسلحتها بشكل ابراهيم
لديهم اسلحتهم ذاكرهم في البلد بشكل اخر
هم لديهم مع البرهان في تحركه كما نعلم
اتفاق الاطاري هم
لمع البرهان ولكن مما تخشى اخشى من
المساله المرحله القادمه اذا
تحولت الى فكر جهوي نحن نتكلم مناطقي اذا
فرضنا انه نعرف انه
مالك عقار من اركوي جبريل ابراهيم جميعهم
من منطقه غرب السودان اذا المساله صار في
تعاطف مع مع حمايه تيفي المرحله الحاليه
المساله راح تنفجر لمستوى كبد جدا ولكن
اذا
هذا عامل مهم اذا العامل الجهوي قد يتحرك
النزعه الجهويه المناطقيه ربما تتحرك عند
هذه القيادات نعم ولكن هذه القيادات اذا
يعني ارتفعت بمستوى الحكمه عندهم وكانت هي
السبب الاساسي في تقريب وجهات النظر بين
الطرفين محمد حمدان دوجلو والب
[موسيقى]
باي شكل من الاشكال فبالتالي اذا كان كما
بين قوسين يقولوا الفلول اذا الفلول
اصبحوا موجودين الطيارات
اللي احنا شفنا لهم القاده العسكريين
التابعين للقوات الحركات المصالحه
باي شكل من الاشكال لانه الصراع دائما كان
بينهم وبين المجموعه التي بين قوس سميت
سنتابع في الحديث بعد قليل ولكن مع ضيف
اخر شاكرين وجودك معنا الدكتور اسامه
المصطفى في هذه التغطيه عن العامل الزمني
وعن الوسطات القائمه حاليا الاقليميه
والدوليه لنرى ان كانت ستؤتي اكلها سريعا
ام لا شكرا جزيلا مره جديده شكرا
نتابع هذه اللقطات التي نشرها الجيش
السوداني لمدير معهد الاستخبارات العسكريه
العميد ركن حيدر محمد احمد في ايدي قوات
الدعم السريع
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
متواجد مع قوات الدعم السريع ومنذ وجوده
وجدت كل تعامل جيد
وكرم ولم
شكرا
اذا يعني واضح انه من نشر ذلك قوات الدعم
السريع لمدير معهد الاستخبارات العسكريه
العميد ركن حيدر محمد احمد في ايديهم
واخر المعلومات تشير عن ان قوات الدعم
السريع غادرت مطار مروي العسكري بعد
اشتباكات عنيفه مع الجيش اظهرت مقاطع
فيديو صورا تظهر معاناه نحو 450 طالبا
محتجزين بمدرسه كومبوني منذ اندلاعي
الاشتباكات في الخرطوم الاطفال المحتجزون
يطالبون الحكومه السودانيه بالوصول الى
عائلاتهم وتوفير مواد غذائيه ومياه شرب
مجموعه من الطلاب الغين في مدرسه كمبوني
باسم الاساس
الحاصل تقريبا كلهم 450 طالب
الاستاذ كله
دانا الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
تاري السقوط قتلى وجرحى من المدنيين في
الاشتباكات الجاريه في السودان بما في ذلك
مقتل ثلاثه موظفين ببرنامج الاغذيه
العالمي واصابه اثنين بجروح خطيره في شمال
دارفور من جهته عبر فولكر بيرتس الممثل
الخاص للامين العام السودان عن انزعاجه
الشديد من اصابه منشات الامم المتحده
بمقذوفات بالاضافه الى تقارير عن نهب
مباني الامم المتحده وغيرها من المباني
الانسانيه في عده مواقع في دارفور
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
العمليات المتمرده يا خاين
نتعرف الان على الوضع في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم لكن من الناحيه
الجغرافيه
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تنقسم الى ثلاث
مدن هي الخرطوم وام درمان والخرطوم بحري
هذه المدن مجتمعه تشكل الخرطوم الكبرى
بعدد سكان يتراوح ما بين 8 الى 10 ملايين
نسمه منهم مقيمون ومنهم متنقلون اليها
يوميا للعمل وكسب الرزق والنسبه الاكبر من
السكان تقطن في مدينه الخرطوم وام درمان
الاشتباكات الجاريه حاليا متداخله في
المدن الثلاث دون وجود خط فاصل بين الجيش
وقوات التدخل السريعه في حال حدوث ما لا
تحمد عقباه واتساع رقعه القتال سيكون امام
قاطني الخرطوم طريق واحد للنزوح وهو
الجنوب تحديدا الى المدن الواقعه على
النيلين الابيض والازرق وفيما يتعلق بسكان
الخرطوم بحري امامهم التحرك شمالا او شرقا
للابتعاد عن مناطق القتال اخيرا سينبغي
على سكان ام درمان انه ددت الاوضاع
الامنيه امنهم النزوح الى المدن الواقعه
غرب وشمال وجنوب ام درمان
اذا الجيش السوداني يشير الى قوات الدعم
السريع بالعدو ويقول انه يلجا الى استهداف
الافراد بالقناصه من اعلى بعض المباني
والموقف مستقر جدا في محيط القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه السودانيه عبر الهاتف من
الخرطوم الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي فريق
دكتور جلال تاور اهلا بك معنا سياده
الفريق ماذا يقول هذا البيان من خلال
المصطلح المستخدم الذي يعني يخاطب فيه
الجيش قوات الدعم السريع بالعدو
القوات الجيش الان طبعا
اولا اطلق عليها قوات متمرده والان اصبحت
قوات العدو قبل بين الجانبين والقتال
المستمر لاكثر من يوم وما زال مستمر حتى
اللحظه في عباره العدو هي مرادفه لكل
حالات تصور الموقف الحالي يعني تصوير دقيق
لانه اصبح هو العدو الذي تقاتله القوات
المسلحه الان
ولكن اليس من يوصف بالعدو الان هو الذي
كنتم تقولون عنه انه جزء جزء من الجيش
عندما كان الكل يشير لكم بانهم قد يشكلون
خطرا
لا لا ابدا هم اصلا كانوا قوه نظاميه
معترف بها ولديها قانون مجاز يعني لديها
قانون وتتعامل قوه معامله القوات المسلحه
ما في شك في ذلك ابدا الخلاف الذي حدث
الان والتمرد على القياده العامه والدخول
في مواجهه ومحاوله حتى الاستيلاء على
القياده العامه ومقراته
هي التي افردت هذا الواقع جديد وطبعا صدر
قرار بحل هذه القوات منذ الامس من رئيس
السياده تم حلها وبالتالي اصبحت الان يعني
قوه خاليه على نطاق الغانم كانت في الاول
هو النظاميه غير
يعني من قاده او من التعليمات لكن اصبحت
الان تقاتل قتال مباشر ضد القوات المسلحه
والقوات المسلحه تتهم الدعم الفريق لانه
هو من بدا الاشتباك وحاول الاستيلاء على
مغرضها وحاول يعني مقر القياده الرئيس
البرهان رئيس الصحيح ولكن الم الم يطل
الزمن قبل ان تحقق هذه القوات المسلحه
انتصارات كامله وحقيقيه وساحقه في بعض
المواقع على الاقل على الطرف الاخر الذي
تسميه العدو نعم كانت لها دور ايجابي جدا
في يعني مناطق التمرد بالذات في منطقه
دارفور والا مالك مشهور انتصرت فيها على
قوات الحركات المسلحه في جوزلجو زاد على
قوات العدو والمساواه يعني عند انتصارات
وعندها دور في تحقيق الامر والاستقرار في
مناطق متعدده من السودان لكن هذا كله يعني
لا يعفي ان اتمردد على القوات المسلحه
وقائض وهاجمت
هذا قصدي القوات المسلحه القوات الجيش
السوداني الم يطل الزمن بها منذ بدايه
المعارك بالامس فجرا حتى اليوم بان تحقق
انتصارات حقيقيه لانه لا مبنى القياده
العامه حسب الموضوع فيه ولا محيط المطار
ولا القصر الجمهوري حتى موضوع الاذاعه
والتلفزيون بعده مش محسوم لماذا
من الذي قال ذلك
البيان الان بيان الجيش يقول الموقف مستقر
جدا في محيط القياده العامه وهذا كلام
غامض صراحه يعني لا يقطع الشك باليقين
لا لا ليس غامضا الان ليس هنالك قتال في
محيط القياده العامه وتمت نظافه المنطقه
المحيطه بالقياده العامه منذ منتصف النهار
يعني لا توجد اشتباكات في هذه المنطقه
والمراسلين والشهود تتحدث عن اشتباكات في
هذه المناطق في مبنى القياده العامه ومحيط
المطار والقصر والاذاعه والتلفزيون بعده
مقطوع البث صحيح لماذا لا يعود البث اذا
كان الوضع مستقرا الاله والتلفزيون لسبب
مباشر هو العطله الذي اصابه غرفه يعني
الاذاعه وغرفه التلفزيون اصداره المقابلات
وما اصيبت منذ اليوم الاول في الاشتباكات
لكن هي في قبضه القوات المسلحه منذ الامس
المناطق التي تتحدث عنها الان نعم كان
فيها قتال وكان فيها لكن الان الاحوال
هادئه اليوم الوضع اختلف عن الامس كثيرا
ما فيش بيان تسجيل صوتي يطلع من السودان
كله تسجيل صوتي تسجيل فيديو يطلع فيه قائد
او زعيدي مواقع
للاذاعه يمكن تزور منها وكان المهم
التلفزيون التلفزيون يعني لا شك في ذلك
اليوم لا يعمل مشكل
حول المنطقه
قيادي سوداني يطمئن الناس حول يسري على
الارض
من القياده العامه لتصبر اصبر تصدر من
خلاف الناطق الرسمي تظهر من هي
الاستخبارات البرهان اصدر بيان كباشي اصدر
بيان ياسر العطاء اصدر كل هذه الان اصبحت
تستخدم الوسائل المعتاده والموجوده لكافه
المواطنين
يعني الاطمئنان موجود لدى الكهافه على انا
اقول لك انه المعرفه نعم لم تحسب تماما
بحيث يصدر البيان النهائيه توقف القتال
لكن الوضع اليوم افضل من الامس لماذا
باعتقادك يعني شو تحليلك العسكري لماذا لم
تتمكن من فعل ذلك حتى الان مثلا لانه
هيديك مجموعات مش منظمه غير مؤسساتيه الى
ما هنالك
انا تحدثت معك انه يعني هذه القوات ليست
بالقوه يعني ليست فصيله او ليست كثيره هي
قوات كثيره ومواقع مختلفه الخرطوم وتم دق
كل مواقعه في اطراف العاصمه والان يجري
ملاحقتها من مكان لمكان داخل الاحياء في
الخرطوم وفي ام درمان على الاقل يعني في
نشاط ماذا مستمر في ملاحظه هذه القوات
البيان الخطابي البيان يظهر في نهايه
العمليه وتوقفه وفتح الاسماء الاسواق
والكبار بهذا عدد الحياه هل انت تخشى
سياده الفريق من موقف متغير لقاده الحركات
المسلحه
الحركات المسلحه حتى الان موقفكم ايجابي
في انهم يعني يتوسطون بين الاثنين ويسعون
الى نزع الفطير الاسمر هم كانوا طرف في
التفاوض بين البرهان وكان هنالك اهتمام
مقرر لهم في صباح اليوم الذي وقعت فيه
الاحداث لكن شاهد الاخبار ان تحدث هذه
تطورت الاحداث اكثر ليس اذا تطورت الاحداث
اكثر اذا يعني قد قسمت البلاد في خطوط
تماس خاصه في المناطق الغربيه مثلا التي
تسيطر عليها قوات الدعم السريع بقوه
اذا استقل سيد حميتي بقواته بنفسه في
مناطق معينه واعلن عصيانا على الاقل وترك
العاصمه الخرطوم هل يمكن مناطقيا ان تبقى
هذه الحركات على موقفها رغم انتماءاتهم
على هذه الحركات وهي اصلا ليست حليفه لها
يعني ليست حليفه
جائزه اتفاقيه وتعمل الان باتفاقيه يعني
عندها مناشده للطرفين لمراعات وحده الوطن
في الحركه الوطنيه السودانيه فلا يتوقع
انه لانه حمايه مناطقهم ينسحبوا اضافوا
ليه لو كانوا يريدون ان ينضموا مكان
ينضموا اليه
لماذا يعني الذهاب في مناطق المناطق
الطرفيه لا يعني
الفريق انا سؤالي الاخير بس يقول بيان
الجيش بانه المعركه ستحسم قريبا يعني على
الاقل في في محيط
المبنى القياده العامه لتحدث عنه لانه قال
الموقف مستقر جدا هل يعني من تقديرات
عسكريه وفق المعطيات الحاليه باعتقادك
يعني المدى الزمني الذي يمكن ان تاخذه هذه
المعارك
في منطقه القياده العامه دي تم حجمها موجه
منتصف النهار
كل اطراف القياده العامه وما حولها والى
اخره تم حسمها الغذاء الاصوات التي تسمعها
الان هي يعني المطاردات لبعض الجيوب
الموجوده في وسط الخرطوم حول القصر وفي
شارع النيل
يعني لتنظيف يعني قوات الدعم السريع بناء
عليه شو بيكون مصيرها في وسطات الان من
الايجاد من المفوضيه الافريقيه مصريه جنوب
سودانيه عربيه امريكيه شو مصير كل هذه
الوسطات
هذه الوصفات هي محل تمبير واحترام رغم
الموقف المتصلب الان مني يعني تصريحات
قاده القوات لانهم لا يريدون ان يستمعوا
الى اي وساطه الا ان يحسموا هذه المرحله
الان المندوب بجامعه السودان جامعه الدول
العربيه
الطلب عدم تدخل خارجي عدم تدخل خارجي في
هذه المساله باعتبارها مساله داخليه وانت
تعلم ان مجلس الامن اليوم مجتمع ناقش هذه
المساله واعطى اشارات غريبه جدا بريطانيا
اوضحت انه ما يجري في السودان هو عباره عن
انقلاب بغطاء يعني
هنالك الكثير من الحراكه العالمي والاقليم
والمحلي لكن هذا لا يوقف رغم الموقف في
القوات المسلحه التي تقول انها لا تريد
وساط الان لا يوقف او يمنع الاخرين من
السعي في التوسط الى ان نصل الى منتهى
المعركه الطلبه الوساطه والسعي للوساطه لا
يتوقف على طرف واحد يتوقف على الطرفين
والسعي الطرف الذي يسعى الوسائط عليه ان
يواصلوا الى مصر بما انك ذكرت موضوع
الجامعه العربيه ومندوب السودان
والتصريحات التي تمت اليوم سنعود اليك بعد
قليل بعد ان نشير اليها فقد اكد مندوب
السودان بالجامعه العربيه سفير صادق عمر
عبد الله ان قوات الدعم السريع هي من
بادرت بالهجوم على الجيش السوداني واضاف
عبد الله خلال الاجتماع العاجل لمجلس
الجامعه لبحث تطورات الاوضاع بالسودان ان
الجيش نفذ هجمات لدحر الدعم السريع
نشير الى ان الدعم السريع هو الذي بدا
الهجوم على مقر السكن رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي في القياده العامه للجيش
في التاسعه من صباح امس
علما بانه كان هناك اجتماعا مقرر له مع
الرئيس البرهان في ذات اليوم
مما يعني يعني
الهجوم الاول كان في نوع من انواع الغدر
رغم الجيش السوداني بتحركات لدحر الهجوم
والعصر الجمهوري ومطار الخرطوم
معتمدين على عسر المباركه لكن القوات
المسلحه كانت لهم بالمرصاد وتصدت
من السيطره على الاوضاع وبسط وطرد
القوات المعتديه
سياده الفريق عدو اليكم تقول قبل قليل انه
الحل داخلي داخلي وفقا لبعض تصريحات ولكن
هناك ارتباطات خارجيه ان كان السودان
كدوله والقوات المسلحه او لقوات الدعم
السريع وبالتالي سيكون لها تاثير كبير على
الارض اليس كذلك
يعني تصب في مصلحه نزع الفتيل الازمه ووقف
نزيف الدم واذا مطلوبه اما من يستجيبوا
متى تتم الاستجابه فهذا لا يمنع الاخرين
من السعي في الوساطه باي حال من الاحوال
نحسب انه كل هذه
الدوله لابد ان يعني نستجيب لي صوره اخرى
في وقت ما لهذه النبات وهذه المناشدات
المطلوبه
للدما في السودان اتفق معك
على هذه النداعات ولكن هل ما الشروط التي
سيضعها الجيش باعتقادك لاي وساطه من اين
ستبدا اي مفاوضات
انما رفض رفض قال يعني حتى الان موقف واضح
جدا لانه لا يريد وسط الان الى ان يحسن
قبوره الداخليه في عراق هو في اشتباه مع
هذه القوات الدعم السريعه هو لم يقول انه
سيضع شروط معينه لكن نحسب انه كشفت
النداءات والمطالبات ممكن ان تغير الموقف
وتسمح بالجلوس الى بعض والاستغناء
الاستماع الى بعض تمام لو حصل ذلك من
النقطه التي يمكن البدء منها ما الذي ما
اقصى ما يمكن ان يقبل به او لا يقبل به
الجيش في التعاطي مجددا مع قوات الدعم
السريع
المشكله اساسا يعني الاعتراض بالخطا اول
حاجه من الذي اخطا ثم ماذا لماذا لماذا
اخطا ثم بعد ذلك التراجع والتراجع عن كل
العمليه الخطا يعني العدوان على القياده
والاساءه والتصرفات والهجوم على فيها يعني
اخطاء لابد ان يتم الاعتراف بها وازالتها
طواليك ممكن يعني ينظر في الحلول التي تتم
فيما بعد ذلك يعني ازاله عنصر التمرد
والعدوان على القوات المسلحه ده لابد من
اثباته اولا ثم بعد ذلك الانتقال الى
مرحله التفاوض والترايا وحسن وحل بقيه
المشاكل شكرا جزيلا لك سياده فريق الخبير
الامني والاستراتيجي الفريق دكتور جلال
تاور تحياتي اليك
رئيس مفوضيات الاتحاد الافريقي ايضا من
المفترض ان يصل السودان الاثنين سعيا لوقف
اطلاق النار وفقا لصحيفه سودان تريبيون
نتابع هذه الصور التي التقطتها الاقمار
الصناعيه لشركه ماكسار والتي تظهر الدمار
الذي حل في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
جراء الاشتباكات حيث تظهر صور الدمار في
جسور الخرطوم والمطار والاضرار التي لحقت
بمبنى القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
عرضت مصر وجنوب السودان الوساطه بين جيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع بعد
المواجهات التي بدات بينهما امس في
العاصمه الخرطوم ومدن اخرى ووفقا لبيان
للرئاسه المصريه فقد نشدت جاره السودان
لاطراف السودانيه تغليب صوت الحكمه
والحوار السلمي وذلك خلال اتصال هاتفي بين
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي ورئيس
جنوب السودان سلفاكير
اذا الجيش السوداني طمئن الشعب الى ان
القوات المسلحه متماسكه وانها ستحسم
الموقف قريبا اكدت مصادر للعربيه ان
تحركات المصريه جاريه لوقف الازمه الحاليه
في السودان وبحسب المصادر فان المبادره
المصريه تاتي بالتنسيق مع الامم المتحده
والاتحادين الافريقي والاوروبي وتتضمن سته
بنود اهمها الوصول لاتفاق مبدئي لوقف
اطلاق النار والتصعيد بشكل كامل وفق اطار
زمني محدد وسحب قوات الطرفين من الشوارع
والمنشات الهامه تحت رقابه لجنه دوليه
المبادره تضمنت ايضا وضع خطه وجداول زمنيه
لتوحيد المؤسسات الامنيه والعسكريه
السودانيه بشكل كامل اضافه الى تشكيل لجنه
عسكريه من الطرفين لازاله النقاط العالقه
خلال اطار زمني محدد للتنفيذ الدعوه لعقد
اجتماع للاطراف السودانيه في دوله محايده
في حال تعثر الاجتماع داخل البلاد ايضا من
ابرز البنوط
اعلن الاتحاد الافريقي ان رئيس مفوضيه
موسى فقي محمد سيتوجه فورا الى السودان
للتحدث مع الطرفين بشان وقف اطلاق النار
حيث من المفترض ان يصل الاثنين
وعبر الاتحاد عن قلقه العميق اذا الوضع
داعيا قوات الجيش والدعم السريع الى حمايه
المدنيين وفق ما جاء في بيان صدر عقب
اجتماع طارئ لمجلس الامن والسلم التابع
للاتحاد الافريقي
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان الوزير
الامير فيصل بن فرحان اجره اتصالا هاتفيا
مع رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
البرهان كما اجرى اتصالا اخر مع نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده محمد حمدانو واكد وزير
الخارجيه السعودي ضروره التهدئه ووقف كل
اشكال التصعيد العسكري بما يحافظ على
مقدرات السودان كما شدد الامير فيصل بن
فرحان على اهميه العوده الى الاتفاق
الايطاليه الذي يضمن تحقيق الامن للسودان
من دبي معنا دكتور حمدي عبد الرحمن استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه زايد اهلا بك
معنا دكتور اريد ان ابدا معك بموضوع
الوسطات هذه على اي منها تعول بشكل اساسي
مساء الخير اولا مساء النور اهلا وسهلا
فيك الحقيقه الحقيقه يعني الوضع على الارض
الخاسر فيهما سكان المدنيين يعني المعاناه
التي يعيشها اهلنا في السودان وفي مناطق
كثيره من الخرطوم وبصفه خاصه في منطقه
بحري من خلال الاتصالات مع بعض الاصدقاء
لا يستطيعون الخروج من منازلهم وفي يعني
حاله يرثى لها طبيعه الصراع على الارض هي
بين قوى
متمرسه في حرب المدن
وتمارس يعني اساليب غير تقليديه يعني مثلا
هتجد قوات الدعم السريعه تستخدم مخزونات
من السلاح قديمه في المناطق السكنيه
وبالتالي مهما كانت عده الجيش واستخدام
الطائرات والدبابات وسلاح المدرعات لا يب
دي نفعا مع هذه الاساليب التقليديه
تتسم بالعشوائيه ولذلك
حتى لا تصيب اهدافها
الى امكانيه ان لا يتمكن الجيش من حسم
المعركه سريعا بسبب هذه الجزئيه
طبعا فكره الجيش كان يتحدث عن فجر اليوم
والان يتحدث عن اسبوع والامور غامضه بين
كر وفر لانه الدعم السريع بقواته التي
تتراوح ما بين سبعين الف الى مئه الف
متمرسين في حرب المدن هذه مساله مهمه جدا
والجيش يعلم ذلك منذ القديم وهذا خلا
ف يعني صحيح صحيح انه كان في مشاكل قائمه
اعود اليها بعد قليل فقط اشير الى ان وزير
المعادن السوداني اذا سمحت لي دكتور يعلن
مقتل اثنين من اسرته وثلاثه اخرين بسقوط
قذيفتين على منزله بالخرطوم وهذا التصريح
من وزير المعادن السوداني الذي يعلن مقتل
اثنين من اسرته وثلاثه اخرين بسقوط
قذيفتين على منزله بالخرطوم وبالعوده الى
المشاكل المحتقنه اصلا بين الطرفين
من يتحمل المسؤوليه هنا في اطاله امد هذا
النزاع دون حل حتى وصل الى الانفجار
الكبير
الى الطرفين
يتحملان المسؤوليه
لانهما كان شريك الاتفاق منذ 2019 كان
شريكين في الحكم وبالتالي الخلاف هو خلاف
الشعب السوداني لا ناقه له فيه ولا جبل
خلاف بين اطراف كانوا يشكلون مكون عسكري
جزء من العمليه الانتقاليه ثم حدث الخلاف
بينهم اعود الى القول بانه اي وساطه واي
تدخل خارجي لابد وان يكون هناك استجابه من
هذين الطرفين لتغليب لغه الحوار كما قال
السيد حمدوك في مؤتمر الصحفي لا بديل الى
لانه حتى لو كان الجيش بيمتلك اسلحه من
القوات الجويه لكي تتخلص من بقايا
الدعم السريع ينبغي ان تدق احياء باكملها
او يمكن السيطره في نهايه المطاف على
المناطق المفصليه في الخرطوم بما لها من
رمزيه
ويتحول النزاع مره اخرى الى نزاع في
الهوامش والمدن الاخرى ويستطيل امد الصراع
في السودان وهذا ما نخشاه
ولكن الاتهام الان لقوات الدعم السريع
بانها يعني تقصف وتواجه
طرفا كان يعتبرها جزءا منه وكان بتصريحات
سيد برهان والقيادات العسكريه الاخرى ان
قوات الدعم السريع جزء من الجيش حتى عندما
كانت تلام على طريقه التعاطي مع هذه
القوات التي يبدو انها تسلحت وتمول ت
وقويات حتى
استقوت على الجيش السوداني الذي ما من
يعني ما من طريقه ممكنه امام الناس
العاديين حتى الا ان يقفوا معه كقوات
مسلحه للوطن
خليني خليني اوضح بالنسبه لهذه النقطه
مهمه جدا
الاصل ان يكون هناك جيش واحد للامه
ويحمي الامه هو حامل امه ولا اي عقيده
قتاليه واحده المشكله التي حدثت في
السودان وفي بعض دول غرب افريقيا وحتى بعض
الدول العربيه هي انشاء اجسام غير عسكريه
ميليشيات ويتم الاعتراف بها من قبل النظام
الحاكم لاداء وظائف معينه او قيام باعمال
غير قذره او غير اعمال يعني غير بروفيشنال
غير مهنيه زي ما كان بيحصل في دارفور
فانشاء هذه الجماعات من قبل النظام السابق
النظام البشير 2013 واطفاء عليها قدر من
الرسميه اصبح عندك ازدواجيه في المؤسسه
العسكريه عناصر ميليشيات لم تتخرج من
كليات حربيه ليس لديها قواعد في الاشتباك
يعني زي ما شفنا في بعض امثله مثل
الاعتداء على الطيران المدني في الخرطوم
ما عندهمش ادنى
الاشتباك لانه مش مش مؤهلين
عسل وبالتالي هذه الجماعات بتتبنى اساليب
غير تقليديه مما يؤدي الى ديمومه الصراع
فهنا سؤال من الذي يحمي السودان من هو
الذي يمثل العقيده القتاليه او الجيش
الشعبي طبعا المفروض تكون المؤسسه
العسكريه اللي هو الجيش السوري الرسمي لكن
فكره الازدواجيه دي والاعترا
ف
بفتره ما قبل ما بعد البشير هي التي جعلت
هذه للزواجيه وخصوصا انت عندك قوات شبه
نظاميه كبيره العدد كبيره جدا
وصلت الامور الى هذه المواصيل للاسف على
امل يعني ان نتحدث عن حل قريب انا يجب ان
اكتفي معك بهذا القدر دكتور حمدي عبد
الرحمن استاذ العلوم سياسيه في جامعه زايد
من دبي اعذرني على المقاطعه ولكن شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه الايضاحات نتابع
واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام في تغطنا هذه
المستمره والمتواصله ساعه بساعه من
العربيه للاحداث الجاريه في السودان الان
ننتقل الى زميل صهيب شراير ومعه الساعه
المقبله فالى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات